on le sait quand on fait du cinéma
quelques images valent mieux qu'un long
discours voici l'hommage des Césars à
celui qui dès la fin des années 50
assuré concilier tous les genres de
cinéma auteur et populaire Jean-Paul
Belmondo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il me fait pas doubler c'est d'abord par
goût c'est pas agréable quand on joue un
rôle que ça soit un autre qu'il fasse à
ma place et puis je crois que si on veut
se faire doubler à ce moment-là il vaut
mieux pas faire des des films d'aventure
si j'ai toujours une bout du riz et goût
du sport et en plus je sens mieux mes
rôles quand je fais tout moi-même
[Musique]
je ne sais pas pourquoi on disait que
j'avais une tête qui pourrait me gêner
pour prendre des dames dans mes bras
[Musique]
pas du tout
j'aime les hommes
grand fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
profitez-en
[Musique]
vous croyez Irène vous êtes le mal dans
toute son horaire
tu es si belle
que je regarde c'est une souffrance
[Musique]
c'est une joie et une souffrance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de l'eau on était indissociable c'est la
vérité
[Musique]
je suis en tatouage
[Applaudissements]